[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale il est
télévision locale vous présente
le club des territoires
et avec nous pour ce club ne casse la
table merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
économiste depuis européenne place
publique c'était la liste de Raphaël
Glucksmann avec entre autres le Parti
socialiste Emmanuel Duteil bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être la directeur de la
rédaction d'usine nouvelle on va parler
avec vous de l'équation que doit
résoudre le gouvernement s'étend
d'inflation comment aider le pouvoir
d'achat des français tout en baissant la
dépense publique on va en débattre le
gouvernement siffle qui présente
aujourd'hui le budget 2024 on verra avec
vous quelques mesures
oui ou pas augmenter les impôts et on va
revenir sur les prévisions du
gouvernement en matière de croissance
c'est un suivi d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Orléans retrouver Éric Richard bonjour
Eric merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à La Nouvelle République on
parle déjà du budget avec vous puisque
votre journal se penche sur l'examen de
ce budget un exercice qui s'annonce
particulièrement périlleux
et oui l'automne on le sait bien et
rarement la saison disons la plus gai de
l'année mais alors pour l'exécutif et
bien cette année on le sait ne coupera
pas à un exercice en forme d'équation
savante il s'agit bien sûr de renforcer
comme promis le régalien notamment le
ministère de l'Intérieur et celui des
armées tout en maîtrisant voire en
réduisant la dépense publique alors le
Conseil des ministres ça prête donc à
présenter on le sait elles sont projets
de loi de finance officiellement d'après
crise puisque le temps du quoi qu'il en
coûte qui était né en pleine tempête
covid et bien et revolut le problème on
le sait c'est que il y a la pré-crise
c'est pas pour maintenant la guerre en
Ukraine ferrage l'inflation galope la
croissance mondiale ralentit et la
perspective à court terme et bien n'est
pas spécialement encourageante le
gouvernement va donc tenter de dégager
vos le disiez tout à l'heure 16
milliards d'euros d'économies dans ce
contexte tendu un peu plus de 4
milliards de baisse de la dépense
publique et surtout 10 à 12 milliards
c'est le grand coup de rabot sur les qui
est tarifaire et autres aide notamment
les aides à la construction de logements
neufs ça a pas rangé non plus le marché
de l'immobilier alors d'accord le
gouvernement l'a promis il n'y aurait
pas de hausse d'impôts mais la
disparition de ces aides aux énergies
notamment qui étaient des dispositifs
devenus essentiels pour les ménages les
plus modestes promettent d'être bien
difficile à avaler car dans le même
temps et au-delà des engagements pris
sur le régalien il s'agira de mobiliser
7 milliards au moins 7 milliards d'euros
sur la planification écologique a déjà
pris du retard voilà en effet vous le
disiez qui promet de nouvelles joutes
sans merci et c'est un air connu entre
le gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
un mot Éric sur les dialogues de Bercy
puisque c'était ses réunions instaurées
par le gouvernement en amont des débats
budgétaires quels on peut en tirer
alors il est très mitigé pour le moins
il fallait sans s'en douter au début de
ce mois dans une interview Elisabeth
borne disons feignait de découvrir ou de
s'étonner que les que les oppositions
assimilaient le vote d'un budget à une
adhésion à la majorité c'est cependant
un peu frappé du point du bon sens pour
l'examen budgétaire qui s'ouvre il n'y
aura sans doute pas de surprises en
l'absence de majorité absolue bien le
recours aux fameux articles 49-3 et plus
que probable le gouvernement semble déjà
si résoudre voir ainsi préparé car à
l'heure où la dette publique de la
France vient de franchir le seuil qui
établissant l'un des trois milliards des
3000 milliards d'euros bien il n'est pas
question de décevoir les agences de
notation après la sanction infligée en
avril dernier par l'agence Fitch une
nouvelle dégradation serait vécue comme
un camouflet par le gouvernement et par
tout le pays alors qu'Emmanuel Macron on
le sait fait une priorité de convaincre
les investisseurs de la bonne santé de
l'économie française on verra bien si
cette force de conviction suffit et on
le verra très bientôt si beaucoup Eric
Richard on regarde la ligne de la
Nouvelle République à Issoudun s'affront
embauche c'est à la Une de votre journal
on va continuer à parler de ce budget
difficile équation on le disait pour le
gouvernement qui veut baisser les
dépenses publiques mais doit aider les
Français face à la hausse des prix parmi
les postes de dépenses le carburant si
l'état refuse pour le moment de mettre
la main à la poche il met la pression
sur les distributeurs qu'Elisabeth borne
a reçu hier à Matignon CCS
vendre les carburants à perte ils
avaient dit non en revanche les
enseignes de la grande distribution ont
accepté hier à l'issue de la réunion
avec Elisabeth borne de vendre à prix
coûtant l'essence dans leur station
toute la distribution a parlé comme un
seul homme ou une seule femme pour pour
se mettre à prix coûtant en tout cas
démultiplier les opérations à prix
coûtant nous savons que nos clients
souffrent et une souffrance très forte
dans sur le territoire autour notamment
de ses prix du carburant on a donc pas
hésité on a décidé de faire une grande
opération c'est la plus grande que
Carrefour n’a jamais fait dans les
stations services Leclerc et Carrefour
la baisse des prix à la pompe sera
appliquée dès vendredi dans les autres
supermarchés elles seront plus
ponctuelles au total jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 128 opérations à prix coûtant
seront organisés dans 4000 stations
elles pourraient se prolonger jusqu'en
2024 selon le gouvernement ces
opérations pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
bien impacter une partie de la
profession les stations indépendantes
qui vont elles continuer à vendre au
prix du marché une grande surface sa
dose bien évidemment à un magasin de
5000 ou 10000 m² chez nous évidemment 40
à 60% de la marge brute de la société
c'est le carburant et puis on a aussi
une double peine c'est que le fait qu'on
nous enlève nos clients quand on baisse
de 30 à 60%, ça veut dire que les ventes
annexes le lavage la boutique et toutes
les bonnes annexes qu'on a développé
depuis des années dans les stations
services justement pour survivre bon
d'être impactés et Isabelle a annoncé le
lancement d'une mission sur les coûts et
les marges de la filière elle rendra ses
conclusions en décembre oh la Luc
Elisabeth borne a donc a priori réussi à
convaincre les distributeurs de vendre à
prix coûtant le gouvernement a donc
réussi à mettre la pression c'est un
début après la question c'est quand on
vend un prix coûtant souvent ça serait
percute sur autre chose par ailleurs il
y a pas que la question de l'énergie il
y a pas que la question enfin il y a pas
que la question du carburant et à la
question énergétique et la question
l'alimentation c'est à dire que
l'inflation aujourd'hui touche un très
très très grand nombre de secteurs et
donc la pression elle doit être mise sur
l'ensemble de ces secteurs
mais juste sur le carburant est-ce que
vous dites opération réussie on va voir
à terme on va voir à terme c'était c'est
un bon début moi je trouve que c'est pas
du tout suffisant voilà c'est pas c'est
pas suffisant ça aurait dû être fait
bien plus tôt à mon sens premièrement
deuxièmement est-ce que ça passerait
percuté comment ça va se récupérer sur
autre chose ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est à
voir votre invité précédent qui a été
centriste ma mémoire est bonne parler
d'une augmentation de la taxation sur
les super profits je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire effectivement
aujourd'hui parce qu'il va nous falloir
beaucoup d'argent pour pouvoir aider les
français Emmanuel Duteil a un risque
effectivement que les distributeurs vont
dans le carburant a pris coûtant il
reporte les c'est ce qui vont perdre
finalement sur le carburant sur d'autres
choses
il y a toujours un risque parce
qu'effectivement il faut souvent se
rattraper autre part après faut juste
faire attention à la mesure c'est
revende à prix coûtant notamment dans la
grande distribution faut pas vendre
durer vos français c'est quelques
centimes ça n'ira pas plus loin que cela
puisque la marge notamment des
distributeurs 60% de l'essence en France
est acheté dans les grandes surfaces
Leclerc Carrefour et autres la marche
chez eux allez 2 à 4 voir 5 centimes au
max du max du max donc c'est ça que les
Français gagneront donc quand vous posez
la question est-ce que c'est réussi pour
le gouvernement moi j'ai plus envie de
dire est-ce que c'est réussi pour le
porte-monnaie des Français ça restera
marginal quand vous arrivez aujourd'hui
à environ 2 euros litres un plein
d'essence d'une voiture à peu près
normale c'est 100 euros aujourd'hui donc
si vous enlevez deux trois centimes par
litre certes c'est toujours mieux dans
notre poche que dans celle d'un autre
mais c'est pas une opération extrêmement
importante pour le pouvoir d'achat il y
avait au début il y avait l'option de la
vente à perte c'est ce qu'avait demandé
Elizabeth bande finalement ça a échoué
les distributeurs on dit non pourquoi ça
échoué est-ce que là ça aurait vraiment
changer les choses pour porte mener des
Français oui et non parce qu'on peut pas
obliger un distributeur une
station-service avant de rappel c'était
vraiment à mon humble avis la fausse
bonne idée c'est à dire que c'est super
on affichage politique on disait allez
nous on a déjà donné beaucoup d'argent
maintenant c'est à vous de faire un
geste le problème de la vente à perte
c'est qu'il y a toujours un perdant au
milieu de tout ça et surtout ça n'avait
aucun intérêt dans le sens où tous les
distributs si tous les distributeurs
avaient dû le faire en même temps là il
n'aurait pas gagné un seul client parce
que celui qui d'habitude fait son plein
chez Super U ou chez Carrefour il aurait
continué à le faire donc là il y avait
même pas l'effet rattrapage que ça
aurait pu permettre d'avoir donc c'était
économiquement irresponsable surtout
pour toutes les stations services
indépendantes en France parce que quand
on est indépendant et qu'on vend à perte
faut pas y avoir fait l'ENA au Sciences
Po c'est juste dire que vous perdez de
l'argent dès que vous vendez un litre
d'essence c'était juste intenable c'est
il faut quand même voir qu'ils avaient
réussi le moyen d'annoncer une aide pour
les consommateurs ceux qui utilisent
leur voiture et en même temps il aide
pour les stations services indépendantes
c'était pas cohérent après je pense que
il y avait aussi peut-être derrière tout
ça le fait qu'elle cas total qui a lui a
décidé de plafonner à 99 au maximum le
prix de l'essence certes il fait de la
marche sur toute la chaîne ce qui est un
peu la grande différence de Total mais
il y a un moment si on doit rester un 99
et que l'essence continue de monter
lui-même va pas être très très loin du
seuil de revente à perte ou en tout cas
du prix coûtant c'était économiquement
responsable l'avant-à-paire vous êtes
satisfaite que le gouvernement est
abandonné cette idée ça a été dit la
difficulté c'était pour les petits en
fait dans dans ce secteur après on est
dans un moment de comment dire de
rapport de force politique c'est du pur
rapport de force politique et dans ces
cas-là face à des gros mastodontes qui
sont organisés qui peuvent faire les
prix de marché l'État doit être en
rapport de force pour pouvoir protéger
en fait les ménages tout simplement et
c'est là où il ne l'a pas été en fait
quand on a une explosion des marges
comme on le voit aujourd'hui que ce soit
sur la question du carburant ou que ce
soit sur la question de l'alimentation
dans ces cas-là je suis désolé mais
quand on est l'état il faut sortir les
moyens pour que pour que les entreprises
reviennent un peu à la raison mais
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire c'est des
fois on peut on peut soit on fait une
augmentation des taxes sur les super
profits c'est ce qu'on a défendu au
niveau européen le dispositif est encore
en place on peut l'augmenter comme on
veut ça c'est le premier point deuxième
point
préadministrer en fait dans des périodes
de guerre et on est en guerre en Europe
qu'on le veuille ou non il va falloir un
peu regarder la situation en face on est
encore en crise comme ça a été dit et on
est encore en guerre on utilise ce genre
de processus qu'en fait du rapport de
force notamment sur les questions
énergétiques pour que les entreprises
reviennent à la raison on utilise ce
genre de processus ça a été fait à Hawaï
dans les années 2000 quand justement le
prix du carburant avait flambé les
États-Unis ont dit bah très bien un prix
administré on fixe les prix et vous
revenez à quelque chose de décent ça a
été fait en Californie même chose sur
l'électricité dans les années 2000 donc
vous voyez c'est pas et cette mesure
ça a été un moment relativement aidant
au niveau français je crois que les
industriels à un moment étaient contents
d'ailleurs et puis par ailleurs on est
en guerre et en plus si vous voulez
l'économie c'est un les outils
économiques ce sont des moyens c'est pas
idéologique moi j'ai pas une passion
pour les prêts administrer du tout en
revanche quand il faut en faire pour
faire du rapport de force quitte à le
faire ou quitte à ne pas le faire et que
ça reste une menace pour que les
entreprises encore une fois reviennent à
la raison bah oui de temps en temps il
faut pas se priver de certains outils on
est la puissance publique on n'est pas
des acteurs privés les acteurs privés
eux vont utiliser tous les moyens
possibles ils ont raison ben nous on
doit faire pareil en fait Emmanuel je
pense que sur les prix du carburant faut
faire attention quand on laisse penser
qu'il y a énormément de marge sur tous
les éléments de la chaîne pour revenir à
la raison de la hausse des prix du
carburant c'est tout simple c'est le
prix du baril de pétrole qui explose ces
derniers mois pourquoi il explose parce
qu'on est sous la pression notamment des
pays producteurs et principalement de
l'Arabie Saoudite qui a dit très
clairement au pays européens et au reste
du monde vous voulez plus de pétrole de
main ben tant pis vous paierez le prix
qu'on voudra et on ne vous aidera pas
c'est la raison pour laquelle les prix
des carburants augmentent donc le
gouvernement a une marge de manœuvre
quand même extrêmement limitée parce que
quand ils vont voir Mohamed Ben
samadier d'Arabie Saoudite il leur dit
très clairement je peux rien faire tout
ce qui est rare est cher et après il y a
effectivement beaucoup de fantasmes sur
le fait qu'on gagnerait beaucoup
d'argent sur la chaîne de production les
producteurs de pétrole gagnent beaucoup
d'argent sur la vente des barils de
pétrole mais qui après sont mis dans une
sorte de peau commun et qui repartent
qu'est-ce qui fait en France après le
prix c'est la raffinerie le stockage la
distribution même un acteur comme Total
perd de l'argent sur son activité
raffinerie en France alors il va pas se
plaindre pour eux ils finiront leur fin
de mois il y a aucun souci je vous
assure mais si on regarde ce qui
constitue la réalité du prix en France
il y a pas non plus d'énormes super
profits parce que ça a été ça a été déjà
plutôt travaillé parce que par ailleurs
le carburant la France est quelque chose
de très concurrentiel et si vous
regardez par rapport le vrai gros
problème finalement du crédit du
carburant en France c'est le poids des
taxes c'est que aujourd'hui plus de 60%
du prix de ce qu'on achète à la pompe
c'est quand même des taxes et la vraie
question c'est est-ce que le
gouvernement pouvait jouer là-dessus
alors les cartons tout de suite la TVA
serait demandé des discussions à
l'Europe je pense qu'en 202 2058 on y
serait encore mais le donc enlevons la
tête
pour ceux qui étaient fait dans certains
pays bien évidemment mais pour ceux qui
proposent de la réduire au taux minimale
à 5,5 ça demande une dérogation on peut
pas le faire sur le carburant en tant
que tel puisqu'on peut pas le faire sur
les choses qui qui polluent qui est
peut-être très bien dans la logique donc
on mange tout un gros paquet de taxes
autre que la TVA sur lequel le
gouvernement peut travailler sauf que à
un moment où on essaye d'envoyer des
signaux pour la transition écologique et
où accessoirement on essaie de faire un
quart de 2000 euros d'économie c'est pas
facile de toucher non plus à cet élément
là une crise des énergies fossiles qu'on
est en train de vivre en fait
fondamentalement c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas voulu anticiper la sortie dans les
énergies fossiles et voilà dans quelle
situation on se retrouve c'est à dire
que les prix explosent alors pour des
raisons géopolitiques pour des raisons
de tension entre pays etc certes mais
franchement c'était prévisible donc les
citoyens aujourd'hui les ménages se
retrouvent dans une situation très très
compliquée parce que on n'a pas voulu
anticiper cette transition écologique
donc il va falloir maintenant que le
budget soit responsable à ce niveau là
et prépare correctement cette transition
écologique parce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de lutter contre l'inflation
aujourd'hui on va en parler du budget
mais un mot puisque vous en parliez tout
à l'heure auront la Luque effectivement
il y a les prix à la pompe mais il y a
aussi des prix de l'alimentaire les prix
dans les supermarchés le gouvernement
dépose un texte parce qu'il veut
accélérer les négociations commerciales
qui pour le moment sont annuel le
gouvernement dit il faut que ça arrive
avant mars il faut que ça aille plus
vite on veut voir des baisses de prix
des descentes vous soutenez ça mais moi
je vais soutenir toutes démarches qui
permet de soulager les les Français leur
vie quotidienne ça c'est évident après
il y a toujours des grandes grandes
annonces dans ce gouvernement et
derrière ça finit sur rien donc si le
gouvernement avait vraiment vraiment
voulu comment dire
faire du rapport de force avec ce type
d'entreprise il aurait fait il y a
longtemps et par exemple je vais vous
donner juste un exemple quand on a parlé
quand on était en train de légiférer
côté Commission européenne et côté par
le mont européen sous ma plume sur la
taxation sur les super profits parce
qu'on disait l'inflation est liée au
noir je des entreprises nous on avait un
gouvernement français Bruno Le Maire en
tête qu'elle est sur tous les plateaux
pour télé pour nous dire qu'est-ce que
c'est que le super profit je sais pas
j'ai jamais vu ça ça n'existe pas etc
donc là même chose il y a un manque
d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement donc la question de la
confiance et la défiance se pose moi
j'attends de voir en fait j'attends de
voir clairement ce qu'ils vont proposer
est-ce que ça va être encore une grande
réunion où ils vont me demander quelque
chose ou est-ce qu'ils vont vraiment
sortir les muscles à travers un texte
qui est fort avoir j'aimerais bien que
ce soit sincèrement énormément de doutes
parce qu'on peut pas dire qu'on a un
gouvernement qui quand il s'agit de
faire du rapport de force vis-à-vis des
grandes entreprises françaises et au
rendez-vous voilà Emmanuel Duteil est-ce
que l'État les moyens de peser sur ces
négociations commerciales
il a fallu des semaines et des mois de
négociations pour obtenir qu'on avance
d'un mois et demi la finalité de la
décision sur les négociations
commerciales donc on peut douter
effectivement de leur de l'impact qui
peuvent avoir donc bon malgré tous ces
mieux que rien de réussir à avancer ces
négociations commerciales après faut
regarder tous les détails du texte c'est
assez rapide à lire c'est un article
donc pas trop de temps il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont exonérés grosso modo ça
ne concerne que les très très grands
groupes internationaux tant mieux parce
que effectivement alors je sais pas si
on peut aller jusqu'à super profil et
concernant mais ce qui est certain c'est
que les données que nous avons donc
l'équivalent la marge brute des des
groupes de l'agroalimentaire des géants
mondiaux de l'agroalimentaire à
nettement augmenté ces derniers temps
c'est en tout cas plus que l'inflation
c'est des donc ça c'est un fait donc il
y a sûrement un peu de marge là on peut
faire baisser les prix surtout que s'il
a aussi on revient la raison de la
hausse des prix il y a quand même une
détente assez nette sur une grande
partie des matières premières qui
constituent le seul problème c'est que
là encore si on parlait de l'avenir pour
les carburants il faut préparer l'avenir
et la transition écologique dans ce
secteur de l'agroalimentaire il faut
être très honnête avec votre
téléspectateurs va conduire à garder les
prix élevés c'est pas parce qu'il y a
ces négociations qu'on reviendra au prix
d'avant crise c'est sûr et certain que
les prix vont rester élevés c'est à dire
quoi préparer la transition c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut progressivement même si on
sait pas très bien comment le faire
aujourd'hui sortir du plastique donc
faut trouver des alternatives qui
sûrement dans un premier temps vont
coûter plus cher faut s'adapter à
l'évolution du climat c'est qu'une
partie de la hausse des prix de ces
derniers mois c'est parce qu'il y a eu
des catastrophes écologiques au Canada
dont on parle assez peu mais des feux
gigantesques qui ravage le pays et plus
près de chez nous le sud de l'Espagne
qui pendant très longtemps nous a quand
même permis d'avoir des fruits et
légumes et des tarifs à peu près
corrects pour au détriment parfois des
producteurs français à la frontière mais
avec en tout cas d'Espagne avec une
sécheresse historique et surtout très
précoce qui a donc il va falloir donc
les Français qui nous regardent vous
leur dites ne vous attendez pas dans vos
supermarchés avoir les prix baissés on
reviendra pas au prix comme avant il va
y avoir des opérations coup de poing sur
certains prix va y avoir certaines
vestes le panier va être un petit peu
baisser par rapport à ce que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui tant mieux on en a
tous besoin mais revenir au prix
d'avancer il faut quand même voir qu'il
y a eu 20% sur les deux dernières années
de au cirque tout ce qu'on en est on
fait tous nos courses aujourd'hui on
voit très on le vit tous au quotidien
dire aux Français les prix il faut faire
très attention à la formulation les prix
vont arrêter d'augmenter certains prix
vont baisser mais on ne va pas revenir
au prix d'avancer alors
oui et non
un peu d'espoir je pense qu'on va aller
à peu près dans la direction deux tiers
aujourd'hui de l'inflation est liée au
super profit est liée à des marges
exceptionnelles qui ne sont pas
justifiées c'est la Banque centrale
européenne qui le dit c'est le Fond
Monétaire International qui le dit plein
de industriels nous expliquent que non
non ils pourront pas revenir à la
normale etc ça c'est du discours pour
justifier l'injustifiable donc là-dessus
les pouvoirs publics ont une
responsabilité et doivent protéger les
Français donc là-dessus on a une marge
de manœuvre extrêmement grande pour
réduire l'inflation après c'est sûr
qu'on doit changer de modèle qu'on doit
passer du toujours plus et du tout
jetable au mieux consommer mieux ça nous
fera tous du bien d'un point de vue
santé pour la biosphère également mais
ça implique un changement de système
économique c'est-à-dire que ces
dernières années on était dans un
système économique où on tirait les prix
vers le bas les salaires les les prix de
l'agroalimentaire etc et là on doit
passer vers quelque chose de mieux
c'est-à-dire augmenter les salaires on a
un taux de provoqué de 15% dans ce pays
inadmissible pour la sixième puissance
économique mondiale sincèrement donc
augmenter les salaires permettre aux
gens de consommer mieux je crois que
tout le monde en fait a envie de pouvoir
consommer des bons de bons produits et
tout le monde est prêt à les payer sauf
que quand on a une pas assez bah on peut
pas les payer donc ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir repenser l'ensemble du système
et c'est là encore que l'orientation
budgétaire du gouvernement va être
importante est-ce qu'on va aller vers
une vraie cohérence en termes de
transition écologique est-ce qu'on va
faire de la politique industrielle pour
de vrai c'est à dire qu'est-ce que sera
pas un mot au vin parce que l'industrie
c'est quand même c'est ce qui paye le
mieux et c'est ce qui protège le plus
les salariés quand même dans l'ensemble
plutôt que les emplois de service donc
avoir tout ça et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui les annonces vont être
assez déterminantes et justement on va
parler de ce budget Steve avec notamment
une question est-ce qu'on va payer plus
d'impôts
de faire le gouvernement la promis il
n'y aura pas de hausse d'impôts dans les
prochains mois dans le budget présenté
aujourd'hui le les taux de prélèvement
obligatoire devrait se stabiliser ils
sont actuellement de 44% du PIB il
devrait passer 44,1% l'année prochaine
dans le détail il y aura quelques
allègements et quelques hausses en
matière d'allègement fiscal la CVAE
l'impôt de production sur les
entreprises va diminuer le barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu va être révisé en
tenant compte de l'inflation en matière
de hausse fiscale il faut s'attendre à
la suppression de l'avantage dont
bénéficier le Gazole Non Routier le
gouvernement entend aussi taxé les
concessionnaires d'autoroute tout ça
c'est évidemment ce que souhaite le
gouvernement les choses pourraient
encore changer lors de l'examen du texte
Parlement alors pas dose d'impôts c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour notre
porte-monnaie mais est-ce que c'est
vraiment ton âge c'est toute la question
d'autant plus que le gouvernement promet
bien de se serrer un peu la ceinture
Bruno Le Maire veut sceller la fin du
quoi qu'il en coûte il prévoit 16
milliards d'euros 16 milliards d'euros
d'économies en 2024 forcément il va y
avoir des perdants à court moyen ou long
terme on nous dit que l'essentiel de ces
économies proviendront et bien de la
suppression du bouclier tarifaire pour
l'électricité le bouclier qui nous
permet bien de payer moins cher nos
factures on ressent d'ailleurs très
clairement cette suppression progressive
puisque depuis le 1er août on paye déjà
nos factures 10% plus cher pour les
tarifs réglementés la hausse des prix va
donc se poursuivre dans les mois qui
viennent jusqu'à la disparition complète
du bouclier qui est prévu au début au
début de l'année 2025 alors des
économies pas d'augmentation d'impôts
est-ce que de nouvelles recettes sont
envisagées ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il faut pas uniquement compter sur la
croissance pour remplir les caisses dans
son budget le gouvernement table sur une
croissance de plus
1,4% l'année prochaine dans le détail
pour remplir les caisses le gouvernement
planche sur une taxation des super
profits des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute sur l'augmentation d'une
taxe sur le gaz il compte aussi sur le
sur les bénéfices de la lutte contre la
fraude ou encore sur l'instauration d'un
impôt minimal sur les sociétés tout cela
est censé apporter de l'équilibre au
budget 2024 au bout au budget des années
suivantes mais certains économistes sont
très sceptiques c'est aussi le cas de
Pierre Moscovici le président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques qui son
avis publié lundi dit la chose suivante
la trajectoire présentée par le
gouvernement demeure peu ambitieuse au
regard des engagements européens de la
France le projet de loi de programmation
ne prévoit pas de retour rapide vers
l'objectif d'équilibre des finances
publiques merci Steve 16 milliards
d'euros d'économistes et le chiffre
principal de ce budget est-ce que c'est
réaliste oui c'est réalise sur le
chiffre qui a avancé sauf qu'on est très
très loin de l'objectif qui avait été
engagé on nous avait dit que ce serait
le grand soir sur le logement on en est
très loin c'est plutôt reporté aux
années d'après on nous avait dit que ce
serait le grand soir sur la suppression
d'un avantage pour ce qu'on appelle le
gazole non routier pour notamment le
système le secteur agricole et tout on
sert tous ça commence cette année mais
typiquement
parce que pourquoi on a tellement été
biberonné à la dépense publique ces
dernières années qu'à chaque fois que
vous voulez en enlever un bout ou
soulevez un lièvre parce que si on
reprend l'exemple du gazole non routier
on peut pas demander aujourd'hui à des
agriculteurs ce qui sont dans une
situation économique très difficile de
pouvoir supprimer ça même si on pouvait
quand même anticiper ce je pense que ça
fait à peu près 10 ans qu'on parle de la
suppression de cet avantage fiscal donc
effectivement je pense que les 16
milliards sont tenables on est très loin
de ce qui avait été avancé on reste très
mauvais dans notre capacité à réduire le
déficit parce que faut quand même voir
que la prévision c'est de rester à 4,4 %
de déficit très au dessus des autres
pays européens et très au-dessus d'une
forme de norme qu'on a tous oublié de
finance responsable en Europe après
est-ce que c'est la faute du gouvernance
je suis pas 3% c'est que 2027 je suis
pas sûr que Bruno Le Maire puisse aller
vraiment beaucoup plus loin ce qui est
un peu inquiétant c'est que le
gouvernement est quand même ce que vous
expliquez très bien un peu basé ces
perspectives sur des jusque là le
gouvernement était assez réalise dans
ses prévisions de croissance parfois
même un tout petit peu en dessous de ce
que prévu les économistes la 1 4 on est
vraiment dans la fourchette très haute
donc à poser un petit problème sur la
sincérité du budget dans un moment et il
faut quand même rappeler ça où on a
jamais emprunté autant sur les marchés
les taux d'intérêt augmentant on le voit
pour ceux qui souhaitent acquérir un
bien immobilier notamment ça a une
énorme conséquence sur les finances
publiques et ça met du coup en question
notre capacité financière vous avez un
doute sur la sincérité de ce budget et
est-ce qu'il fallait les faire c'est 16
milliards d'économies alors déjà un
budget c'est pas qu'un exercice
gestionnaire c'est un message politique
c'est le premier message politique de la
rentrée c'est ça qu'il faut aussi avoir
en tête donc la question elle veut
savoir quelle va être le message
politique du gouvernement est-ce que ça
va être du bricolage est-ce qu'on va
avoir un message et un cap politique
très clair est-ce que ça va être
protéger les Français faire la
transition écologique qu'est-ce que ça
va être au juste moi évidemment
j'aimerais que ce soit protéger les
Français vers la transition écologique
l'inflation c'est son premier combat
alors si l'inflation c'est son premier
combat je suis désolé mais il prend pas
de la bonne façon voilà très très
sincèrement c'est à dire que il va
falloir faire encore une fois du rapport
de force avec les grands entreprises il
va falloir réfléchir auprès de
l'industrer il va falloir faire la
taxation sur les super profits va
falloir mettre tous les moyens sur la
table et investir investir un message
français on va voir ce que ça va donner
mais sincèrement je pense pas que ce
soit ça donc ça c'est le premier point
ensuite il nous faut du sérieux c'est à
dire que moi je fais pas partie des gens
qui disent que la dette publique est un
problème par ailleurs on a un vrai sujet
qui est le niveau d'être privé en France
et on en parle absolument à Parlement
absolument jamais mais l'endettement des
entreprises est un vrai sujet en France
donc je fais pas partie des gens qui
disent que ce n'est pas un sujet je fais
pas partie des gens non plus qui sont en
train de dire que c'est dramatique
l'état de nos dépenses publiques etc
néanmoins il faut avoir un peu de de
sérieux les impôts vont augmenter à un
moment je veux dire il va nous avoir des
recettes les impôts vont augmenter et la
question est de savoir qui va subir
cette aux impôts qui va participer les
impôts reposent aujourd'hui bien trop
sur les ménages le capital n'est plus
assez
la finance n'est plus assez taxée dans
ce pays et donc il va falloir remettre
de la justice fiscale mais en tout cas
la ligne du gouvernement qui en fait un
espèce de point de fierté quasiment très
doctrinaire en disant on ne va pas
augmenter les impôts on ne va pas
augmenter les impôts ce n'est pas
tenable en fait il va falloir augmenter
les impôts la vraie question c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les impôts reposent à
deux tiers sur les minages c'est
beaucoup beaucoup trop donc est-ce qu'on
va faire de la est-ce qu'on va revenir à
une taxation sur la fortune je l'espère
c'est ce qu'on propose nous au niveau
européen on est ça devient un consensus
au niveau des économistes même les
millionnaires et les milliardaires sont
en train de dire taxer nous je crois
qu'il va falloir faire montre un peu de
solidarité ces dernières années en fait
je déménage sont ressorti quand même
affaiblis de la crise du covid de
l'inflation d'autres sont au contraire
sont sortis très renforcés les très
riches sont sortis très renforcés de
cette crise donc un peu de solidarité ne
ferait pas de mal dans ce pays c'est pas
tenable la doctrine de dire pas
d'augmentation des impôts ça dépend
parce que jusque là si on regarde quand
même les perspect si on regarde les
performances du Gouvernement sur ce
point purement économique ça a plutôt
bien fonctionné c'est à dire que la
baisse des impôts ne s'est pas traduit
par une baisse des rentrées fiscales
bien loin de là c'est à dire que la
croissance a permis de faire rentrer
plus d'impôts que ce soit sur les
ménages mais aussi et principalement sur
les entreprises et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement maintient cette idée de ne
pas augmenter les impôts parce qu'il ne
veut pas casser ce qui est finalement
son seul levier c'est la croissance
française parce que d'autres non
regardent beaucoup le verre à moitié
plein puis on a raison parce qu'il y a
quand même des zones d'inquiétude mais
si on regarde le verre j'ai dit quoi à
moitié vide
si on regarde le verre à moitié plein
c'est quand même extrêmement intéressant
de voir que pour une fois la France
résiste mieux que la moyenne de des pays
européens d'un point de vue purement
économique d'un point de vue purement
croissant on fait beaucoup mieux que
l'Italie on fait beaucoup mieux que que
l'Allemagne qui est quand même en quasi
récession et qui va rester sur mon
récession donc
on arrive juste à la fin de ce débat
peut-être juste la réponse d'horreur la
lutte puisque vous êtes député
européenne la France insiste mieux que
les autres pays en personne non tant
mieux si on résistant mais si on résiste
ça a été quand même parce qu'on a un
État providence premièrement
deuxièmement l'Espagne est un pays qui
va relativement bien par exemple
l'Espagne a une politique excessivement
cohérente et c'est celui qui a le moins
d'inflation aujourd'hui au niveau
européen parce que c'est que le premier
jour de ce marathon budgétaire ça va
aller jusqu'en décembre j'espère qu'on
aura le plaisir de vous recevoir à
nouveau pour un